the one thing I'm the most happy about
in terms of my career is the fact that I
got there just by working hard not
partying with the right people not
compromising myself in any way or
cutting any kind of deals just by
working hard just by plugging along
sawing wood as I like to call it I'm a
20 year old one night sensation I found
that nothing in life is worthwhile
unless you take risks
nothing Nelson Mandela said there is no
passion to be found playing small and
settling for a life that's less than the
one you're capable of living now I'm
sure in your experiences in school and
applying to college and picking your
major and deciding what you want to do
with life I'm sure people that told you
to make sure you have something to fall
back on make sure you got something to
fall back on honey but I never
understood that concept having something
to fall back on
if I'm going to fall I don't want to
fall back on anything except my faith I
want to fall forward I figure at least
this way I'll see what I'm going to hit
fall forward this is what I mean
Reggie Jackson struck out 26 hundred
times in his career the most in the
history of baseball but you don't hear
about the strikeouts people remember the
homeruns fall forward
Thomas Edison kentuc did 1000 failed
experiments did you know that I didn't
know that because the 1,000 and first
was the light bulb fall forward every
failed experiment is one step closer to
success you just watched two amazing
clips from Denzel Washington take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]